bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors michel barnier le
négociateur en chef de l'union
européenne sur le brésil qualifie
d'ambitieux
ce projet d'accord qui pourrait définir
la future relation entre londres et
bruxelles qu'en pensez vous à titre
personnel je pense tout d'abord que la
présentation de ce projet de traité de
cette première ébauche montre
l'incohérence je ne veux pas dire
l'hypocrisie de la commission européenne
la commission européenne qui est chargé
de négocier avec le royaume uni ne cesse
de répéter depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois qu'il est très difficile de
négocier un accord de libre échange en
si peu de temps vous vous souvenez vos
spectateurs le savent que le royaume uni
voudrais conclure cet accord avant la
fin de l'année est d'ailleurs boris
johnson a dit qu'il ne permettrait pas
un nouveau report de la fin de la
période transitoire
or nous voyons avec la présentation de
cette ébauche de cette première ébauche
le document comme vous l'avez dit qu'il
fait plus de 400 pages que finalement la
commission européenne a dans ses tiroirs
et bien des traités type qui peuvent
effectivement qui pourrait théoriquement
être signé demain donc cette affirmation
selon laquelle il faudrait des années
des années pour négocier un accord et
tout a tout simplement fausse en fait
quand bruxelles dit que c'est il est
difficile de négocier un accord en un an
ce qu'elle veut dire c'est une façon de
jouer aux cow coeur dans une négociation
ces deux c'est une façon de reporter le
plus longtemps possible le nez si je
puis dire le dernier moment c'est-à-dire
de pousser les gens à tout conclure à la
fin c'est la tradition à bruxelles de
tout faire au dernier moment où après le
dernier moment donc voilà ce que
m'inspire cette cette première ce
premier pas qui est pris par bruxelles
effectivement dans les négociations avec
londres et comment va réagir londres
vis-à-vis de ce document londres va
réagir négativement parce que malgré
toutes les mises en garde et toutes les
toutes les déclarations très lucide de
londres sur ses lignes rouges et bien
bruxelles les affranchis avec ce
document il y en a sur tout
d'abord londres refuse toute juridiction
de la cour européenne de justice au
royaume uni londres 10 depuis maintenant
plus de six mois depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de boris johnson que dans les
futurs rapports entre bruxelles et
londres
il n'y aura pas de rôle pour le la cour
européenne de justice c'est à dire que
un break site qui laisserait le royaume
uni sous la juridiction de la cour de
luxembourg ne serait pas un brick site
ça c'est la première ligne rouge or dans
ce traité dont ceux dans cette première
version d'un traité et bien bruxelles
demande à ce que le royaume uni reste un
sujet ou aux arrêts de la cour de
luxembourg
la deuxième grande ligne rouge c'est la
pêche le royaume uni ne veut pas donner
comme cela a été le cas comme cela est
le cas depuis 40 ans depuis 50 ans ne
veut pas donner ses eaux territoriales
ne veut pas donner l'accès à ses eaux
territoriales à toute l'union européenne
elle veut au contraire retenir le droit
de donner l'accès parents de donner une
licence à des bateaux étrangers chaque
année et de ne pas leur donner libre
accès indéfiniment
or la pêche est évidemment un sujet de
grand conflit avec bruxelles puisque les
eaux territoriales britanniques sont
très grandes
et encore une fois dans ce nouveau
traité est bien bruxelles demande de
très exactement la chose que londres
avait refusé au préalable
alors le gouvernement du premier
ministre boris johnson insiste sur le
fait qu'il ne demande rien de plus qu'un
accord de libre échange avec l'union
européenne et se dit même prêt à
sacrifier l accès au marché européen en
échange de la liberté de rédiger ses
propres lois
pourquoi est ce que bruxelles veut aller
plus loin pour garder malgré tout la
mainmise sur londres pour punir le
royaume uni est bien d'avoir voulu
quitter l'union européenne oui oui
essentiellement c'est cela alors on peut
le formuler autrement mais je suis
d'accord avec avec vous avec ce que vous
dites dans votre question
la grande
menace pour bruxelles c'est une menace
existentielle existentielle parce que si
le royaume uni et ont quitté l'union
européenne et ont quitté le marché
unique et ont quitté la juridiction de
la cour européenne de justice si le
royaume unie prospère comme je crois
qu'il va le faire ou plusieurs raisons
et bien cela représente une menace
existentielle pour l'union européenne
puisque ça va donner des idées à
d'autres
d'autres pays vont commencer à se dire
bah tiens si le royaume uni arrive à
commercer et à bien se porter malgré le
fait qu'il a quitté l'union européenne
pourquoi pas pourquoi nous ne ferions
pas la même chose et c'est cette c'est
cette peur devant la menace
existentielle que représente le brésil
pour l'union européenne qui la motive
il ne faut jamais oublier l'union
européenne dit toujours deux choses
quand les critiques et elle dit d'abord
l'union européenne l'europe c'est la
paix
ça c'est la première chose et ensuite
elle dit l'europe c'est la prospérité
alors pour la paix c'est un autre
argument mais pour la prospérité
c'est un des arguments clés en faveur de
l'union européenne alors il se trouve
que l'une le royaume uni est déjà plus
prospères qu'un grand nombre de pays sur
le continent et notamment de la zone
euro si le royaume uni continuent à
prospérer et bien cet argument de la va
tomber un plat est ce que vous croyez
vous john locke landes un plein accord
entre bruxelles et londres avant le 31
décembre avant elle à fendre la delà de
la période de transition
oui je le jeu j'y crois mais tout peut
arriver
je pense que si je pense qu'il est je
pense que ce qui va se passer c'est que
les deux parties vont vont dire en
public et en privé qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord qu ainsi qu'une situation de
désaccord va continuer pendant assez
longtemps et que peut-être à la fin
dans la deuxième moitié de l'année ou
même en décembre que finalement on
trouvera un compromis mais avant de
trouver un compromis il va falloir que
le royaume uni se prépare à la fin de la
période transitoire sans aucun accord
qu'elle
qu'il joue donc au poc au poker
politiquement qu'il a kill qu'il fasse
semblant ou que que réellement il se
prépare à quitter la période transitoire
sans aucun accord pour forcer bruxelles
a à faire des compromis mais le royaume
uni lui aussi va sans doute faire des
compromis
c'était le cas avec boris johnson avant
avant donc après son arrivée au pouvoir
et avant les législatives puisqu'il
avait réussi lui à négocier un nouvel
accord de retrait cet accord ce nouvel
accord de retrait donc dont l'europe
avait dit au préalable qu'ils n'étaient
pas qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être
renégocié a été renégocié mais les deux
les deux parties londres et bruxelles
ont changé leur position
je pense que la même chose arrivera
d'ici un an c'est ce que nous verrons à
partir de mercredi pour le deuxième
round des négociations à londres john à
auckland merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
universitaire britannique est
spécialisée en géo politique merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup